[Music]
pewdiepie here
master public speaker but it wasn't
always like this
oh no no i work my way there by doing a
bunch of public appearances so i thought
today
why don't we just watch them see how i
improved or gotten worse who knows
i've done a lot more public uh media
stuff than i thought
the very first thing i can remember was
appearing on swedish television
we have two free channels in sweden i
think or is it three i don't know one
and two and four i think are free
all alright at least one and two i know
is run by the state that's like our
version of bbc
it looks so awkward to film yourself
thank you
i'm glad people feel like that
apparently not many people have found
this
video keep it that way oh god so this is
my very first appearance and i was so
excited about it
it was like uh feeling like you finally
got recognized because i i thought i was
doing something really
unique for sweden at the time at least
oh god he's just playing video games
all the time why is there a duck behind
you huh what do you do all day
huh what's wrong with playing video
games why are you guys saying like that
who are you
joe rogan so let's go back to um
i think was it there we go so you can
swear on swedish television
that's great um the play delivery we
don't care
oh it doesn't even say me on the door
because i was renting that
flat second hand that that's how poor i
was i couldn't rent it directly or find
one
just had to rent from someone else mean
that's how poor i was i was still
renting so clearly i had money
i don't know that's my family dog
that's not even my dog and i was like
she lives here
that's a lie oh
and this is the kitchen why do they make
me do this
[ __ ] producers they they want to make
stuff oh that's just
right there by the way i always talk
about it there we go shut the google
they
producers always they're the fault
you're the fault you're the problem
because they're like all right so like
uh can we get a shot of you like walking
in here and showing your kitchen
why why if this happened to me now i'd
be like no
that's so weird oh they have something
and that was my desk do you see you can
barely
fit a keyboard on this desk and it's in
the living room
that was my lightning oh my god
whoa see i could barely fit the
microphone on the desk i remember we
would keep falling down
um
she's saying that uh old people
basically boomers
thinks pewdiepie has the weirdest job
oh my god do you see how clouded my
desktop is
oh that's disgusting well i'm glad i
see how many tabs i have open bro cringe
bro look at this
clean clean sheesh cringe felix
damn that takes me back so much
i don't know what software i'm using but
i used that for years
for i haven't seen her in so years
i think that's the built-in one oh my
god in windows this takes me back
80 hours played amnesia based i don't
know
it's so awkward when they're like oh
okay so now like film your videos
and like we'll just be amaya
it's so awkward when they always come in
and they're like all right yeah now
now like do your thing and we're we're
just right behind you hovering above you
it's like when you're trying to type
something on a computer and someone
comes up behind you and like what are
you writing and i'm like
stop staring [ __ ] i can't type if
you're looking at me
it doesn't work like that stop hovering
and this was already a weird thing at
the time like no one did let's plays or
[ __ ] like that so
um
all right that's another thing that
media people do
they want to get another thing of you so
they ask you a question right
she asked me how many people watch your
videos and i go 30 million
yes
and i'm like all right right now i have
30 million a month so they
they don't respond to you they just
don't say anything because they want you
to save something else
because we naturally fill the gap so
she's purposely not saying anything so
she can make it awkward for me i hate
that
see that
damn stupid media people in their stupid
media training all right so i thought we
would go to
samsung and see what they are doing over
here
i want to continue somehow to be active
for my fans
oh today i am
but i think i'll do other projects in
the future
i guess i did it
maybe even bigger hey well i definitely
got bigger
this is crazy i forgot about this
yes
oh that's right i wanted i wanted to
make my own horror video game
but i never did i wanted to make video
games hey we made pewdiepie pixeling
still relevant downloaded goddammit
i'm not really that interested in the
horror genre anymore but yeah i did have
a lot of ideas for horror games
and i always thought the horror genre
after amnesia it got a bit
tired you know amnesia did it so well
that it spawned a ton of clones
which was really fun for a while but
after a while it sort of killed the
horror genre a bit
i think because people weren't
innovating enough and i always thought
that was so weird because
horror is such a genre where you can be
really creative with who knows
who knows who knows [ __ ] it i can do it
i have money reclaimed
internet program
nice one uh they're basically explaining
how more money is going into the
internet
out of the pocket of all the media
and this is back in 2012 so truth bumps
how's it going bro my name is
this guy was really nice he was like
he's a talent and he speaks well in
english
so a lot of people can watch it and i
mean dad i love you
it's not worth it it's not worth it
oh my god can you pick me up i can't
move
no
[Laughter]
why is this making me emotional i don't
know
i don't know so much has changed so much
i'm not sure what he's saying but it's
it's he sounds smart
then they brought up some blogger and
then they showed me these posters
[Music]
so i did these posters where i told
people hey i can write you can write
whatever you want on this and i'll write
it for you
bad idea
we saw a living room filled with posters
we're not more self-observed now it's
just that more people are watching
again
he's saying oh he's just playing video
games and talking over it
that's crazy and then he says but that's
not what he does
but he's making stand up in a way this
is a totally lame pewdiepie party but
okay i'll roll
with it hey how you doing you come here
up then
[Laughter]
i forgot about this so i'm basically
saying you know how people always told
you
you'll never get anywhere by sitting in
front of the computer or your entire
life and here i was like
but yeah i made it then
[Music]
but i proved them wrong all right so
that was pretty much
bro bro bro
so proud i'm so proud we made it bros
we made it hell yeah didn't expect to be
uh so hard hitting the first time
there's too much i i could make three
part series out of this
this was another crazy one i did it was
in 2012
and it was uh in bilbao bilbao was a
really cool city i've never been there
it's in spain
i was speaking in front of audience who
i don't think they spoke english that
well
and i also don't think they really
understood what i did
it was not a good speech can you even
hear me
what happens in the future youtube is
revolutionary
it's something stable you you knew it
youtube had potential
uh but something stable is funny i think
youtube been pretty
good at staying stable but you know
other social media platforms especially
seeing tick tock now getting banned or
whatever you never know what's gonna
happen with this new media
so it always felt like a big gamble to
put all your cards into this
youtube thing it obviously was but it
paid off am i a trend
yeah i guess i wasn't
[Laughter]
and i talked about it wanting to make a
game as well look at me
going on stage dying of nervousness
wait what is this this is the red carpet
of ender's game
so basically what they do on these i
didn't know this they have a guy that
goes before you and tells all the
paparazzis like
this is pewdiepie he's he's important
because of this and this reason
take photos of him now but the
paparazzis have no
chill cause like if you're not important
they they don't bother
like sympathy photos or something
because they they they told hey can we
do without my sand it's like why did i
why did i let that happen
big mistake should not have later go
but i think martial didn't want to be in
the spotlight anyway so i think it was
okay but
still yeah look at that yeah we're
together
beautiful she's beautiful how can you
not want to take photo of her
all right this is another swedish one a
year later is this fun
i can't tell it i like it it's fun for
me so shut up
[Music]
it's funny because i i still feel like
that all the parents come up i'm sorry
i don't know who you are i'm like it's
okay i don't care
i'm so sorry i don't know why you don't
subscribe
well subscribe then
do is you upload short videos oh no no
we got to get that watch time they're
long videos
this is so lame finally we know what his
thoughts sound like
he sounds softer in swedish yeah swedish
is kind of a
soft language isn't it what sort of to
me
he sounds like a villager thank y'all
[Laughter]
it's so familiar yet unrecognizable whoa
what the [ __ ] is this
seven years ago whoa
hey green dress stop putting your hand
in his face wait what
worst interviewer ever oh god what is
this
have you picked up anything that you
like in the architecture when you look
out
oh i guess that side where the garden is
that's really cool i don't know what it
is though
it's trying to figure it out what it is
it's a garden it's like oh it's the only
garden okay
it's a garden i figured it was a garden
but yeah and
the blue thing is the sea you know oh
yeah it's beautiful i love it
i always wanted to live next to the
season and then i did i moved to
brighton
oh god i have not had a bad meal here
yet let's just say that
very good now can you do a trademark
thing to a marina bay says just do
whatever your trademark is uh how's it
going marina bay science my name is
beautiful
and i enjoyed staying there god wanted
cringe
hey nailed that handshake though nailed
that handshake though
whoa singapore was insane can you
imagine going for my tiny little flat
this is a year
before having like a couple thousand
subscribers
to this environment where people are
screaming
it was insane that was probably the most
insane experiences of my life
a year later god damn i look handsome
here
look at this dude
[Applause]
nailed that handshake nailed that
handshake felix well he damaged his hand
that's why
thank you thank you you're welcome thank
you
very nice to have you on the show uh you
sorry about the norway thing it's just
you weren't supposed to know about that
well we found it you know uh the thing
is that we
we could speak swedish but out of
politeness we're speaking
look at my face be like good
and you actually live here in england
that's right yeah yeah so i'm actually i
moved to the uk at that time at this
point so it's all good
what what we saw here now was it was
that was clips excuse me of interviewers
i understand why felix hates us
norwegians now this interview wasn't
enjoyable at all all those questions
were stupid
really it's from your youtube channel uh
and
and you must explain please explain you
you play computer games
pretty much yeah any video game there is
that is i like the stupid and silly
games
that no one ever plays i like to find
these
yeah that was my thing at the time like
no one would ever play them because they
were so bad
but then i'll i'll commentate over them
and
make it into comedy somehow so so what
you do
you film yourself while you're playing
pretty much yeah
i it's kind of a ridiculous thing i
just commentate while i play video games
it's oh
almost like he said oh god i get it
like back in the day no one understood
what it was and they would always ask
and i never had a good answer i'm like i
play video games and then i talk over
them and i don't know what else to say
so we're talking about marching here
this might be interesting so i just had
a couple followers
one of our friends in italy she's from
italy uh
she sent uh an email to her with
my video in it saying look at this idiot
playing video games
so apparently she liked that idiot but
[Music]
so much that she married him yeah
you you you went not knowing her at all
yeah online yeah you say what you want
about the interviewer but i'm not really
good here either like i'm not giving him
much to work on
keeping my questions very simple so
i don't know you can tell i'm not really
that good i was much more relaxed here
which was backstage afterwards i get
really tensed up when i get nervous and
i think you can
help your fans and a good way to do that
is to
give them a name that's very common for
example i call my fans the bros
so how would you call your fans well the
oldest the oldies
with passion yeah i like yeah
tip number two there's a lot of um
technical aspects for example if you
encourage your fans to
like the video and subscribe you have to
tell them to do that that helps so
please like this video
and subscribe yeah i think that's pretty
good
see i'm much more natural it's almost
like i'm taking charge of this
thank you so much
oh that was close way oh i got
war flashbacks just coming in out of
nowhere what that what
why would you do that in front of me i
misunderstood a handshake
and good luck with the with your channel
yeah good luck with your channel too
thank you thank you subscribe subscribe
see it's so much better felix is one
handsome guy yeah i look so much better
here they got
good makeup on me man look how i look
like now like a little
actual meatball with pubic hair on the
face what is this huh
god damn time's changed man the years
have not been good on me man
uh next one i did was stephen colbert
welcome to television
which was so fun uh i didn't know who
colbert was
so i felt like i was so much more
relaxed on this one because it wasn't it
didn't feel like a big deal people told
me like oh stephen colbert he's huge
like that's a big deal
but i was like i think it worked in my
favor i never seen him so nervous and
uncomfortable well i guess it didn't
work in my favor
oh my god oh god i wish i could do this
now
i wish you could do it now i feel like
i've gotten so much better you know
i want to do it again yeah i used to be
so much more worried than
depends and nervous i still get but it's
way there i feel like it's way different
now
damn he looks nice he should start his
own minecraft series
why am i so wonderful i just made up a
bunch of words like flipping flopping
and they would censor it the necker
worker would sense and be like god we
can't have them saying flip and flopping
oh god helvetta
oh that's good helmet that's funny
uh see that's a good like comedian
making
observations and she said yeah i got i
got a lot to learn man
i can sense how awkward pewdiepie is
thank you guys thank you for your
encouragement of me trying to
be less introverted and weird in front
of people it really helps to have these
sort of comments in the back of my mind
next time i do a public appearance
i really appreciate that he seems kind
of uncomfortable i think he's gotten
more confident since then which is great
i definitely have and i'm very happy
about that
it's weird i think ironically the reason
why i'm not on tv anymore is the reason
why i'm probably able to be more
comfortable on tv now because
all the controversies i think that's
what helped me uh
grow more less self-conscious about
myself i guess
but yeah i wasn't conan as well and it's
i it's just
pure cringe because i was such a huge
conan fan like
look how i'm sitting there it's like oh
god
what is happening are you nervous about
playing with me uh
you know i think you should be nervous
yeah i've seen you play conan
you're pretty pretty awful i'm terrible
i can't get
my play all right it's a little better i
love how defensive you guys are about me
in the comments
pewdiepie cringing so hard at the first
person shooter games
hey first shooter games i can't get that
my character to lift his head to see
where he's going yeah yeah
i literally can't i have trouble and
then i
cringe cringe all right that's about as
much as i can
stomach that's as much as i can take but
i gotta say
um youtube has given me such a weird
unique experience
of growing as a person that no other
environment
in the world i think would have made me
so i'm very thankful for
doing all these things that i was
terrified of doing as an introvert
especially
it was i was dying inside anytime you
feel like you don't want to do something
and you
you go through with it at least me i
always feel like it's always worth it
and it's good to remind yourself of that
and you'll grow as a person for it
because next time you'll have that
experience in the back so push yourself
in life because it will always be worth
it if i had to force a little message at
the end there
that's it thank you for watching this
video thank you for subscribing and i
see you guys
simp merch tomorrow hit up ah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
hoopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean